bonsoir
personne n'a bougé
pourquoi faire du secourisme
d'abord ça change tout le temps et
peut-être des gens qui ont été formés il
ya quelques années
moi ça remonte aussi et j'entends
souvent dire n'en parlais tout à l'heure
wen et le secourisme ça change tout le
temps c'est vrai ou pas puis le
secourisme
c'est super grave parce que si je touche
ça peut être encore plus grave vrai ou
pas et moi ça fait ça fait quelques
années que j'ai mis les mains dans
bifteck
j'ai entendu terreur de parler de case 1
càs de kas 3 on va essayer de rester
dans la case 2,6 g bien mémoriser les
cases et au moins autant que faire se
peut là j'ai simulé stimuler quoique
avec mon âge et les cheveux qui commence
à colorer faire gaffe je suis passé la
visite médicale
c'était tout bon il y aurait plus de
50000 personnes en france qui ferait des
arrêts cardiaques immérité en séries
qu'en médecine
je veux un médecin mais c'est vrai qu'en
médecine l'été en sont toujours très
clair quand une douleur est formidable
vous avez une douleur exquise
je crois que c'est au niveau des côtes
si je peux me permettre
ceux qui ont des côtes cassées et vous
êtes tombé si vous n'êtes pas passés
chez l'orthopédiste vous avez été témoin
consultez votre médecin et quand ils
appuient juste sur le bas vous faites et
on dit ah ça c'est une douleur exquise
et bien il ya des gens qui font une
double feinte qui font pardon un arrêt
cardiaque qui méritait cet arrêt
cardiaque il méritait c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas fait ce qu'il fallait pour
il fume pas ils boivent pas non j'ai pas
trop gras et pourtant ils ont un
problème cardiaque
cinquante mille personnes mourraient en
france de ce genre de chose près de 60 %
pourraient être sauvées si les gens
autour faisait certains gestes des
gestes relativement simple que censément
tout le monde devrait faire
argentan souvent à l'école on devrait
former tout le monde alors pourtant le
niveau baisse on entend ça des fois le
niveau baisse à l'école avant on passait
certificat d'études avant y'avait pas
l'informatique
avant il n'y avait pas tout un tas de
choses aujourd'hui on développe à ce qui
paraît on apprend potentiellement le
même nombre de choses
enfin les mêmes choses peu plus
développé plus et allez donc on est
peut-être un peu moins bon des fois en
mathématiques mais on a d'autres
connaissances en secourisme
il suffit de faire des gestes il suffit
d apprendre alors peut-être que l'école
pourrait mais c'est aussi partout dans
la vie de tous les jours et déjà si ce
soir à la fin de la présentation
vous êtes capable de me dire que le seul
ch ce quitus et de rien faire j'aurais
gagné mon pari et je remercie les
organisateurs notamment victor dans ma
voix réalité pour ça parce que c'est
vraiment ça à chaque fois qu'on en
discute des gens disent moi je préfère
rien faire être en compte
s'ils avaient quelque chose de plus
grave ah ouais ouais
quelqu'un va quelque chose j'ai des
origines du sud de la france il ya des
pleureuses mais vont pas vous décoincer
ce qui bloque on voit des parents qui
vont retourner des enfants les secouer
dire des fois ça marche bien portants
des claques dans le dos 80% 98 % pendant
des obstructions total brutale comme ça
en mangeant s'en vont ce sont des gestes
simples alors que si on fait rien je
vais appeler les secours
évidemment tout le monde sait comment on
appelle les secours le 15 le 17 le 18 ou
le 112 le 196 j'en passe et des
meilleurs mais tous ces numéros là son
justin je ne vous dis pas de bêtises
mais sont peut-être pas forcément adapté
donc on va choisir comparaison si c'est
médical on va plutôt appeler le 15
et on va demander des va demander des
conseils voir l'intervention d'une
équipe médicale
mais le temps qu'ils arrivent même si
ces quatre cinq minutes je sais pas si
vous faites beaucoup d'appelés mais
tenir 4 5 minutes en apnée ça va être un
petit peu compliqué alors que claques
dans le dos va suffire pour un bébé ça
va être adaptée tous ces gestes là sont
facile facile à apprendre la douleur
thoracique qui malheureusement je vous
dis touche beaucoup de personnes déjà
c'est de l'avoir c'est de poser les
bonnes questions ne pas hésiter alors là
je m'adresse plus aux jeunes car quand
c'est les parents qui font ça là et que
le jeune demande à son parent qu'est ce
qui t'arrive tu as mal au thorax ne
t'inquiète pas tout va bien c'est rien
et pourtant après quand il se passe
quelque chose de grave
j'y ai pensé à nous les plus anciens des
fois d'accepter que nos jeunes pose la
question mais que nos jeunes soient
capables de dire aussi et leur envie
j'appelle j'appelle les secours parce
que ça a pas l'air d'aller
c'est pas parce que vous appeler le 15
que de toute façon une équipe médicale
va arriver que des pompiers vont se
déplacer et qu'on va être qu'on va être
passée par là c'est pas la troisième
guerre mondiale quoi on peut très bien
aussi appelé pour avoir des conseils ses
conseils vont souvent salvateur
mais il ya plein plein plein d'autres
choses quelqu'un d'inconscient or ici en
bretagne ça arrive rarement
plus tôt jeudi soir samedi soir quelles
que soient les raisons pour laquelle la
personne est inconsciente et bien va
falloir mettre dans une position de
sécurité mais des fois j'entends ouais
mais si elle est tombée bah ouais si
elle est tombée à lait tombé du 5e étage
quelque chose qui s'est passée à brest
1-1 salle est tombé du 5e étage est
atterrie est là quand les secours sont
arrivés elle avait rien strictement rien
sauf que cette personne si on l'avait
laissé sur le dos elle serait morte
noyée
un coup de chance à l'été sur le ventre
c'était sûrement pas seulement ça qui
l'a aidée elle est tombée aussi sur une
voiture alors qu'on dit est tombée et
elle avait 3 g 23 je crois c'était le
soir de son anniversaire
dès samedi il était 20h vous voyez est
tombé par la fenêtre
moi s'en est bien sorti je vais aux
anniversaires mais cette personne là si
on l'avait laissé sur le dos en se
disant elle a peut-être quelque chose de
fracturer et bien évidemment il pouvait
y avoir des effets délétères pouvait y
avoir des effets secondaires voire la
personne serait morte
voyez ce que je veux dire donc ainsi on
apprend les gestes qui sont relativement
simple c'est facile à apprendre en
quelques heures on apprend à mettre
quelqu'un comme ça sur le côté on lui
sauve la vie et c'est s'est donné à tout
le monde c'est une crise d'épilepsie
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas mangé c'est
un simple petit malaise ça n'arrive
jamais à nos étudiants qui ont entravé
par les deux premières années mais il
arrive en 1ère année c'est la fête
enfin certains auraient été étudiant moi
je suis toujours matin c'est la fête
n'ya plus les parents enfin bon ça fait
un moment je suis un petit peu
débarrasser de ça mais on ne mange pas
on sort tard le soir et qui demain matin
on est en cours et tout d'un coup on
fait un malaise
c'est affreux que un collègue tombe
perdre connaissance et que personne ne
puisse rien faire j'ai pas vous mais le
sentiment de d'impuissance et pour
certains enfin pour nous enseignants je
crois que en un amphi et tout d'un coup
quelqu'un qui fait un malaise
bon ben ça me laisse coi ça se traite si
tout d'un coup on ne peut rien faire
ça va être un moment de panique pour
nous mais aussi évidemment pour les
personnes qui sont autour
que ça soit un repas de famille ou quoi
que ce soit il ya quelque chose d'un
gars l'arrêt cardiaque 50000 personnes
60% son sort est sauvable 5 à 6 % de la
population est formée suivant certains
chiffres
d'autres chiffres avec la journée
d'appel la journée d'appel on va dire
ont eu une information au secourisme
c'est super c'est super et effectivement
il faut le développer
mais avec les anciens qui ont été formés
il ya longtemps les gens qui sont encore
formés de manière un petit peu à des
initiatives locales
on serait allé entre 7 et 10% de la
population formée qu'est ce qui se passe
quand quelqu'un fait un avc un avc ça
vous dit quelque chose à un avc accident
vasculaire cérébral y en a qui suivent
ça toucherait en fin d'année dernière il
y aurait eu cent quarante cinq mille
personnes à faire un avc déclaré
quarante cinq mille morts ouais quand
même
alors que souvent il est possible de
faire quelque chose il est possible
d'intervenir notamment d'appeler les
secours
avec des choses simples pour voir si
c'est une petite défaillance de demander
à la personne de lever les mains donc si
je vous dis pas comme ça on dit au quai
est ce que tu peux recommencer
bon d'accord on lui dit pas et qu'à côté
qui marche c'est mal barré
on peut lui demander parler de chanter
de sifflet et on voit tout de suite un
côté qui marchent plus en plus à une
aphasie né me plais j ai mis
moitié-moitié plis pu et bien tout de
suite il va falloir appeler les secours
oui mais j'appelle pour les secours
parce que grand mère elle fait ça
régulièrement
ça s'appelle un a été un accident
ischémique transitoire
c'est un espèce de on va dire de
bouchons qui se promène dans les tuyaux
et tout à coup qui bloque alors il va
priver d'oxygène
une partie du cerveau et ça va avoir
exactement les mêmes signes
que un accident vasculaire cérébral sauf
que il est pas trop gros ou alors la
circulation sanguine va pouvoir
l'éliminer et la personne va revenir et
elle revient très bien et là on se dit
on est passé à côté de quelque chose de
vain puis qui au bout de sept huit mamie
mais mes freins véritable accident
vasculaire cérébral il y aura des
conséquences première cause de handicap
en france l'avc donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'hyper important et
pourtant vous voyez si au début des
signes
on appelle même si c'est un a été un
même si c'est un petit accident
transitoire on appelle on va faire une
petite exploration garder un petit peu
dans la tuyauterie et on va pouvoir
éventuellement mettre des choses en
place pour éviter d'arriver à l'accident
suprême quoi mais c'est c'est plein de
choses comme ça les apprendre les gestes
qui sauvent c'est quelqu'un qui fait une
hémorragie
eh bien je sais pas si je vous dis
quelqu'un saigne du nez qu'est ce que
vous faites spontanément
j'en vois pas beaucoup j'ai de la chance
je jouais moins bien que vous voyez mais
qu'est ce que vous faites
ouais enfin cm2 la tête en avant et tout
ça ouais
puis on a aussi vont peut-être me dire
on va mettre la tête en arrière voir on
va mettre un élastique sur l'extrémité
de l'auriculaire opposé à la narine qui
saigne ouais ça existe on rigolait pas
il y en a ils mettent des pièces dans la
poche opposé on a eu de la chance
d'avoir des conférenciers qui nous ont
parlé du monde entier je crois qu'au
japon
ça peut être adéquat sous et qu'on mette
des petites des petits chocs comme ça à
l'arrière au niveau des cervicales
suivant le saignement évidemment eh eh
bien tout ça c'est bien joli mais tu es
la tête en arrière qu'est ce qui se
passe est bien le sang passe à l'arrière
et continue à couler et puis il va aller
dans l'estomac
je sais pas si certains ont été opérés
dans le sage est ce qu'on vous a fait
opérer tant de sagesse et qu'il ya un
point qui lâche vous avalez un petit peu
de sang publie ses 10 ans c'est
l'estomac et tout ça donc c'est le sens
où régurgiter le sang
alors je le dis bon apparemment c'est
filmé mais apparemment il n'ya pas de
vampires parmi nous je sais pas si
c'était un secret je sais qu'il ya
certaines séries télévisées qui qui nous
prouve le contraire
mais ce sont des films et nous il ya des
classes ou l'estomac et un petit peu
remplis de sang n'ont pas cuit enfin pas
cuit on va régurgiter et bien dans ces
cas là le saignement de nez va faire
pareil s'il ne s'arrête pas et qu'on met
la tête en arrière nasa continue avaler
ça continue à l'est dans l'estomac et on
n'arrête pas l'hémorragie
vous voyez ça ça fait partie des gestes
qui sont qui luttent contre les les
les transmissions sociale ma grand mère
disait que quand il y avait une brûlure
fallait mettre du beurre
bon aujourd'hui en bretagne enfin
notamment en bretagne le réseau d'eau
potable est développé n'a pas besoin de
mettre les doigts dans le beurre quand
on s'est brûlé
on va pouvoir mettre de l'eau par plus
cet ol est plutôt des fois on la trouve
d'ailleurs même un peu trop javellisée
donc elle est plutôt pas mal quoi donc
sur une brûlure c'est intéressant
bon et sur n'importe quel boulot on peut
mettre de l'eau dans un temps j'entends
pas sur une brûlure grave non c'est ta
raison d'accords quand ces noirs etc ça
fume c'est que c'est cuit
bon ça c'est ça c'est leur autisme mais
tu es quand même de lokua m'étais quand
même de l'eau vous voyez ce sont des
gestes on parle de gestes qui sauvent
mais vraiment il sauf vraiment faut les
faire ne ne rien faire c'est laisser la
personne potentiellement mourir alors on
peut le faire
silencieusement religieusement on a un
copain qui fait juste un malaise on
laisse enfin le malaise du jeudi soir et
c'est typique quand même aux étudiants
et à brest peut-être mes fans ont trois
jours à brest on boit pour un corps
trois jours dans l'année
c'est ça mon temps la personne qui fait
son malaise qui est inconsciente qui
respire pas si vous la laissez sur le
dos potentiellement il va mourir
elle peut se noyer ça c'est important si
vous avez appris les gestes tout à
l'heure on a fait un petit atelier faire
du massage cardiaque c'est pareil c'est
grave ou pas de faire du massage
cardiaque
elle peut-être qu'en même temps c'est
grave
si je faisais un massage cardiaque un
massage cardiaque que ça c'est quand
c'est un massage cardiaque
nous on répare les compressions
thoraciques on va comprimer le thorax
on va faire des compressions thoraciques
est-ce que c'est grave de faire des
compressions thoraciques à quelqu'un qui
a un coeur qui bat ça c'est la question
qu'on se pose problème et s'il est
encore le coeur qui bat bon une femme
c'est pas dur le massage cardiaque vous
voyez comment faire un massage cardiaque
chez une femme
surtout quand on la connaît bien on
prend sa main on appuie dessus
régulièrement vous savez pertinemment
qu'elle a le coeur sur la main
donc le coeur est là il ya des
footballeurs parmi nous ce soir et un
match il ya déjà de briques site et un
match le coeur à ça c'est coeur des
footballeurs après on sait pas trop ça
c'est mon coeur je pense à toi
le choeur est pile poil entre les deux
là entre les deux parties du thorax et
c'est là qu'on va publier ça tombe bien
c'est la partie un petit peu souple on
va pouvoir appuyer là et si je fais le
massage cardiaque
enfin les compressions thoraciques
excusez moi à quelqu'un qui a le coeur
qui bat c'est pas grave ça changera rien
vous risquez pas d'abîmer la personne
ouais je peux lui casser les côtes ou
deux c'est pas grave alors attention
dans mon propos n'entendez pas il faut
casser des codes pour faire un massage
cardiaque efficace ça c'est si ça arrive
quand vous le faites c'est pas grave ça
se répare chez tout le monde vous croyez
non chez vivent seulement donc si vous
faites rien avec les codes sont cassés
malheureusement on n'aura rien d'autre à
faire que d'attendre donc le seul geste
qui sauve en fin ou le seul geste qui
tue plus tôt c'est lequel a votre avis
ne rien faire je vous remercie
c'était juste j'interviens régulièrement
donc avec les étudiants mais
j'interviens aussi j'ai la chance je le
dis j'ai la chance et une passion c'est
pas un métier j'ai la chance d'être
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
j'ai la chance de mettre les mains
dedans d'intervenir et de sauver mais on
est super bien formés là je fais de la
pub pour mes chefs s'il me voit je les
salue
on est super bien formés mais si vous si
la personne qui à côté ne fait rien
malheureusement on arrivera toujours
trop tard
donc les gestes qui sauvent c'est la
personne qui est à côté
sauve qui peut celui qui sait celui qui
sait et celui qui a envie de faire
donc il faut absolument et c'était le
message que je voulais vous faire passer
ce soir
apprendre les gestes qui sauvent mais
surtout les faire donc n'hésitez pas on
compte sur vous merci beaucoup et bonne
soirée